all right guys here it is the most
anticipated camera of 2023 the Nikon Z8
so many of you been talking about this
on YouTube on forums I've been guessing
what are the specs on this and we're
going to talk about all that right now
you pretty much know the specs if you
already saw the announcement uh video
but here we are we're going to talk
about this compared to the z9 which is
the right camera for you how similar to
this is it to the z9 and what are the
key differences you need to know about
let's get down to talking about the Z8
but before that here's a message from
our sponsor here at geek culture we've
tested plenty of Chess but Secret Life
gaming chairs remain one of our
favorites whether it's for work or play
they feel great to lean back against
with the ergonomic features offering
support for the whole body from the head
and back
to the arms and even something for your
butt this mix of format function helps
the Titan Evo 2020 to deliver the best
seating experience like no other for
more information check out secretlab.co
before we kick things off I do want to
give a big shout out to Nikon Singapore
for providing this pre-production camera
having said that these are my thoughts
and my thoughts only this is
pre-production so when the final
firmware comes out when we get a retail
unit in for the full review we will talk
about that but this is more of a first
impressions so let's get down to talking
about the Z8 first and foremost how
different is this from the z9
reality is they're very very similar
what Nikon has done with the Z8 has
pretty much given you a z9 and a body
that is 30 smaller and significantly
lighter the z9 is 1 340 grams this is
990 grams this is made of magnesium
alloy and carbon fiber you really do
feel the lightness of this camera it
feels really really good in the hand now
it is larger than the Z6 and z7 z72
respectively but it still is
significantly smaller than the z9 which
a lot of you were complaining about
because you love the z9 performance the
video functionality 8.3 K and raw 12-bit
prores 4K 64k120 you love that camera
but it was bigger even for photographers
out there
but the Z8 has all of that in a smaller
body so that's essentially it let's talk
about some of the key differences right
now first and foremost when you look at
the body design right now there's
something a little bit different than
what the leaks were showing you remove
that burst mode dial that's on the top
of it which a lot of them were showing
but that was just sort of a mock-up it's
all flat now you still have all your
buttons here your modes your your Burst
Mode white balance and bracket all that
is here you just remove that dial so it
gives it much more of a sleeker look on
the side of the camera here the ethernet
Jack is gone now you can use it via a
USBC adapter but now you have two USBC
ports one for charging and one for
tethering a lot of people wanted that
option to have two USBC ports Nick on it
listen to you it's in here so another
attribute that I really like about this
camera is the battery drawer there's no
lock on it now on the z9 that was a
really tough situation you had to push
down and then push to the side no longer
just push the side opens up
automatically however you only have one
CF Express type B card slot in the Z8
and a uhs2 card slot very similar to the
Canon R5 so if you're looking for
redundancy then the z9 may be the camera
that you want however I've been using a
one CF Express type B card for the last
eight nine months I've had no issues
with failing no issues whatsoever so I
don't think you're gonna have that here
with the Z8 I have a 5 12 gigabyte card
and I don't need a second one it has
that much storage in this and that's
shooting 8.3 K and raw video and 4K and
doing you know 30 and 60 frames per
second photography as well so no issues
with that as well okay moving on to the
design of the camera outside the grip
feels really really good feels really
robust it feels very similar to the z9
minus the uh vertical grip however you
can attach a vertical grip to this which
will give you hot sauce Mobile Battery
uh support on that and you have a usb-c
port in that so you can actually charge
that as well speaking of which this
battery is the same as the z62 and z72
respectively now in terms of the zipper
rating I don't pay attention to those
because when we got the super rating for
the z9 it was like five or six hundred
shots and I got thousands of shots so I
don't even know where the super rating
comes from but if there's any Testament
to the how the z9 performed I think the
Z8 will probably surpass the secret
rating so don't even pay any attention
to that we will take some shots in some
video later on today we're actually
recording on the Z8 right now uh Zachy
is recording me what are you ready 4K
10 bit 4K 30. good luck on your editing
have fun with that recording time so I
should talk about that real quick there
is not a significant difference this
still does 4K 68.3 K all that stuff
however if you're going to set this up
to high temperature you can record it
the 90 minutes with 8.3 K up to 60
frames okay if
you want to go down to the standard
temperature setting is 60 Minutes
however just set it to high temperature
because it's fine right
um the z9 will go up to
125 minutes they're about so you'll get
a 35 minute difference on AK but
honestly I don't see people recording
that long in AK to be honest with you I
mean 4K is relatively exactly the same
so again for the majority of people out
there this is going to be more than
adequate um outside of that though the
rear display is exactly the same it
flips up and tilts exactly how you saw
in the z9 the button layout is very
similar the evf on this is the same 3.69
million.evf however there is one benefit
to this evf versus the z9 and that is
this is the brightest evf on the market
going up to 3 000 lumens
low light photography low light video no
issues with this evf the auto focusing
system has been improved slightly and
now can detect planes and cockpits now
we don't have any planes or cockpits
here but they say it has been improved
so we're actually going to test riding
motorcycles seeing how it tracks the
performance on that also there's skin
softening and portrait Impressions skin
softening we've seen this on the gfx 100
Series where it softens the skin you can
do that now in photo and in video and
you can uh adjust how soft you want it
to be however in video you can only
record skin softing with a bit now
portrait Impressions is a very cool tool
because depending on the person that
you're photographing right they the skin
tone may not match exactly now we find
this with Asian skin tones African
Americans or darker skin tones for that
matter someone who's really white Like
Me Maybe you want to add a little bit of
tan to me that might help as well so
what you can do in this camera system
now it can actually adjust the skin tone
pigment to match what you see with your
eye to match with to go inside the
camera system now there's very simple
and you can fine tune this as well this
is a really nice attribute we're going
to test that as well because Xeno and
Zaki are much more tan than me
you know you got you guys gotten bad in
the sun yeah you know look at Zach he's
sleeveless right now so with that we're
gonna do some tests with this camera
take some photos take some videos watch
me doing video right now but actually do
some skin softening portrait Impressions
all that great stuff let's see how the
Z8 performs all right so first we're
gonna try skin softening now we have the
85 1.2 on This Love This lens by the way
on the Z8 feels really good on this by
the way and we're going to try it
without skin softening and the autofocus
is just bang on there you go one two
three
that's a 1.2 beautiful now we're going
to go to skin softening now there's
various different modes on this you have
high low and normal so here's low
not much difference to be honest with
the zaki's got pretty good skin he
washes his face he gets facials and
stuff like that it's pretty good you
know let's go to normal
nice
and then we're going to go to High
nice yeah high is like very smooth you
know if you want to look five years
younger Zaki looks like he's 15 now it's
just a little wrong you know
so yeah it's it's just a slight uh
effect it's not overly aggressive it's
not like smartphones it's very natural
to be honest with you but it's nice if
you're shooting like females or males
that help you know some bad skin or some
pit marks and you want to soften them
without using a lot of Photoshop you
know you can use this way so I believe
this only goes in jpeg by the way
speaking of which you can also now shoot
with a Z8 and heif files as well so that
gives you another added benefit but heif
files are tricky because some computers
how they render them and how they they
can open them it just really depends I
found them to be hit and miss but you
have that option here in the camera
system and it's also 10-bit as well now
one of the cool things about the skin
softening mode is you can actually have
it set to the same as your photo mode or
you can change it depending on how you
want to go there with this so I'm going
to start with high now you can only
shoot an 8-bit and we are going to
record real quick now I don't have an ND
filter so I got to bump the shutter
speed on this but it is what it is
exactly move around a little bit
wow look at that skin softening wow
normal
I'm shooting at 1.2 so I can't see
anything but your eyes everything's
blown out
great is it shooting it low real quick
here
we're shooting at 4K 30.
h.265 8-bit
plenty for social media but I know some
of you video files out there want to go
10-bit or 12 bit all that fun stuff but
you know
it all gets compressed anyway
I hate to tell you this right Zacky yeah
yeah
there we go this is zero skin softening
this is Zaki El natural wow this lens is
amazing man
I'm significantly older than you so why
don't you try it on me to see how it
performs right because you've got a
young baby face still how about someone
older more mature like me and see how it
goes
it's like what 65. yeah you know had a
good doctor yeah
skin softening on high how do I look
good yeah it looks smooth right do I
have that Kardashian Glow
I guess when you blow it up on the on
the screen you're gonna see more of it
yeah yeah
oh okay now let's try the portrait
Impressions this is with different skin
tones to see how this adjusts on this
and also you can fine tune it and what
I'm going to do is I'm pulling out the
atoms ninja 5 so you can actually see
how this works all right so now we're
gonna move to Portrait Impressions on
this and I am going to be recording them
any so you actually see what I'm doing
here we've got three modes so we're
gonna go to mode uh we're gonna go to
off first take a look at how this looks
all right now we're gonna go
to
mode three
this one's a little bit warmer mode
three is a little bit more warmer so you
see exactly a little bit more tan out of
it the evf so mode 3 is more pleasing to
him because right now as I see him I
mean obviously we're we've got this kind
of gray light coming into play so it's a
little bit more wider but here you got a
nice warm kind of a Natural Glow to you
which looks nice so if you're doing
weddings or stuff like that you want
that look that's where this one's going
to come into play so you can adjust it
how you want it to be on this you want a
little bit more red into the skin tone
you're seeing that right there so now I
got a little more red I'm cutting out
that sort of that warmth that yellowish
to his tone now I've added a little more
red into that so depending on how you
want to do that now this works for Asian
skin tones it looks for anybody for that
matter but especially if you're shooting
darker skin tones or something that has
or the skin tone there's a certain
pigment to it certain cameras have a
hard time Nikon has sort of adjusted
with this which actually helps out quite
a bit all right so we're waiting for
Zaki to get all suited up here which
he's in a sleeveless shirt so it doesn't
really make a difference so we're going
to shoot him here on the 7200 F 2.8 on
the Z8 uh in terms of the balance
obviously I've got the atomus ninja 5 on
this but I will tell you I've used the
atomas ninja 5 on the z9 quite often for
a lot of my reviews and that is a heavy
setup this is significantly lighter and
this also feels really good in the hands
so I think for a lot of you out there
you're going to like the size of this of
course there is a external battery grip
to this which actually does make it
taller than the z9 and we'll show you
what that looks like right here but for
the most part I think personally if I
was to own this camera I would keep like
this for the majority of the time unless
I'm using a super telephoto lens
something I really need that weight
distribution that's going to help me out
a lot better for the grip and the
handling that's where I would go for the
external grip but then again that's
where the z9 comes into play so the more
I use the Z8 I see what the z9s benefits
are I mean a lot of people will say why
the z9 I mean the Z does most of it true
but the z9 has those benefits of the
Dual CF Express type B card slot so that
gives you the redundancy if you want it
also it is a smaller footprint overall
when you have that vertical grip or the
battery grip versus the Z8 and that grip
so there are some pros of the z9 so they
still make it a flagship camera even if
the Z8 is pretty much all the same
internally for the specs and the z9s are
going to get some of these upgrades as
well too don't think that Nikon's going
to leave the z9 out in the dust or not
there's more updates coming they told me
there's a lot of great features coming
to the camera system far above what
we're seeing here in the Z8 and based on
their update frequency and what they've
already added to the z9 since it
launched I think we're going to be in
for some really exciting treats ahead
anyway Zachy you ready
oh wow wow wow
wow
it kind of farts
[Music]
Eva hey Tom Cruise sold a little bit I
gotta set up the camera first okay
foreign
work for the most part I worked
relatively well only on the portion when
zaki's coming down here there's some
cars in the background so at a moment to
grab those cars but it did lock back on
exactly as he was coming in it tracked
all the way in and you were going
relatively quick yeah
Tom Cruise he goes really fast on a
motorcycle now we're going to try video
then I'll get on the bike and you take
over video let's rock and roll
[Music]
thank you
oh and it checks the motorcycle real
nice look at that
is sweet
not tracking it very nicely
[Music]
okay sniper boot camp
let's go
one more time the things we do are for
what guys don't forget to like And
subscribe okay
[Music]
yeah
that's my mommy
[Music]
so for the most part I kept the uh
autofocus on white with the vehicle
detection and it's really working
flawlessly
oh I'm not working flawlessly in this
heat man won't go as fast as you because
my bike wants to go this like two will
you settle faster
don't blame the bike
now in terms of accessories for the Z8
we have the mbn 12 which is a vertical
battery grip which is also hot swappable
case in point you can charge it by USBC
if you want to do that Ori you want to
open up the battery compartment you
press the yellow tab a single battery
will come out you can swap this as the
other battery is powering up the camera
or if you just want to take the entire
tray out you can do so you have the
entire tray right here
so and we also have the vertical grips
controls right here if you want that as
well so you are
fully ready to go Nikon has done a great
job with this now in terms of size it
does make it taller than the z9 weight
feels roughly about the same here's the
z9 in terms of comparison we'll see what
it looks like so
this is the z9 and this is the Z8 with
the mbn 12. so you can actually see the
difference right there so if you are
someone that does need a vertical grip
most of the time then obviously the z9
may be the camera to go for but if
you're someone that doesn't use a
vertical grip but it only needs it once
in a while depending on if you're using
let's say super telephoto lenses or if
you need extra battery power then this
is a great option and I think for
videographers out there you're going to
really enjoy this but if you're going to
put this on a gimbal I would say remove
the NBN 12 and just use the camera as is
next in terms of accessories yes small
rig has already made a cage for the Z8
right here Nikon and small break have
had a really good partnership over the
past number of years especially with
their smaller cameras and they have
brought out the cage so when you get the
Z8 which I'm sure a lot of you are going
to do and you want to cage for this
it'll be probably available for
pre-order or order as soon as the Z8
isn't out so uh there you have it looks
good and yeah definitely a must-have I
use the smaller cage for the z9 it's a
little bit a little bit large for that
but I think with the Z8 it will work
beautifully yeah by the way Xeno likes
the fact that there's an allen key he
didn't realize that in small rig devices
there's actually Keys like there's a key
down here to tighten it up and there's a
key here in the grip Xeno you learned
something new today huh no you did so
final thoughts on the z8s
um it's the camera everybody's been
wanting I know a lot of people have been
asking for a 16 megapixel sensor and
perhaps we will see that in the future
there is no z8x I don't know where that
rumor came from I think people were
thinking that Nikon was Panasonic but no
there is one Z8 to the market it is a 45
megapixel sensor the same as the z9 and
the same performance uh for the most
part obviously minus some of the
recording limits in terms of timing
based on battery power but
this is essentially the camera that a
lot of people out there have been
wanting and I think a lot of you are
going to really enjoy and in terms of
price point we don't have an exact price
point here in Singapore as of the time
of this recording it is recording in
advance we will let you know in the
comment section below but uh I'm a fan
I've been using the z9 for the past year
as I mentioned it's one of my favorite
full-frame cameras of 2022 and I think
the Z8 is going to be probably right up
there for 2023 this is a phenomenal
system and there's really no Faults to
be honest with you I mean
it is what it is guys this is the camera
everybody's been waiting for and I think
they're going to sell out and it's
probably going to bring you back order
hopefully there's not but if there is
wait patiently you're going to enjoy it
when it gets in your hands anyway those
are my thoughts on the Nikon Z8 let me
know your thoughts in the comment
section below if you like this review
check out more of our camera videos
right here